let's talk about Judge Andrew Napolitano
for a second I'm not a big fan of former
Judge Andrew Napolitano he's a fox news
contributor type he wrote a pretty good
piece though and I wanna talk about it
he wrote a piece on reason.com about the
debate over trying domestic terrorists
in a different way than so-called
regular criminals in the US by
effectively abandoning due process of
course due process generally defined as
fair treatment through the normal
judicial system especially as a
citizen's entitlement and I'll put up
the first of two quotes i want to
discuss from andrew napolitano
reason.com article quote it should come
as no surprise that no sooner had the
suspect in the recent New Jersey and New
York City bombings been arrested then
public calls came to strip him of his
rights send him to get MO and extract
information from him this is more blad
amir putin than james madison and in his
article on reason.com andrew napolitano
goes on to say more about this and i'll
show you quote number two I have often
argued that it is in times of fear
whether generated by outside forces or
by the government itself when we need to
be most vigilant about protecting our
liberties I make this argument because
when people are afraid it is human
nature for them to accept curtailment of
their liberties whether it be speech or
travel or privacy or / due process if
they become convinced that the
curtailment will keep them safe but
these liberties are natural rights
integral to all rational people and not
subject to the government swim either we
change these rules for everyone or we
don't and I would argue that changing
them is dangerous the entire point of
due process is that we have basic ground
rules that are not up for interpretation
depending on what the crime is that
someone is suspected of because that
subjectivity is very very dangerous this
is actually all related to a sort of
perversion or distortion of how this
idea of we should treat terrorists
differently even sprung up the idea that
terrorists could be held without due
says comes from thinking well we're
gonna be overseas and we're gonna
capture people in what we would
colloquially described as combat
situations domestic terrorists were
never supposed to be handled in that way
we have a criminal justice system that
is perfectly well equipped to uh deal
with terrorists many of them have been
charged convicted and and put away what
are we saying when we say well certain
people or certain crimes here in the US
can be arbitrarily excluded from the
constitutionally granted criminal
justice system behalf because what it'll
be a deterrent to future terrorists who
really believes that and this is not
just a theoretical discussion whether or
not he can achieve it Donald Trump is
made it very clear to the extent that he
even understands this issue he will try
to remove many constitutional
protections when Trump talks about
trying us terror suspects in military
tribunals when he uses coded language
about toughening libel laws against
media when he talks about religion based
bans on people coming to the US he's
really getting at the heart of the
American Constitution and to be clear
not excluding Hillary Clinton from any
of this there are concerns with Hillary
Clinton as well but there is no doubt
that would be hypothetical President
Donald Trump would go way further and I
haven't even dealt with executive
actions that he might pass so this has
real-world implications and I actually
do agree with former Judge Andrew
Napolitano on this gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial
for the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s